thanks for joining us America Samantha's
with us in Seattle welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show Samantha hi Dave it's great
to talk to you you too what's up in your
world well I have a question regarding
my husband student loan it has both his
and my father-in-law's name on it and
for the last 10 years or so we've been
paying it exclusively well he before we
were married and then us after and we
the original agreement was that are in
my in-laws were going to pay half and
every time my husband has approached
them to help us pay and they have
refused and so now is it fit well I
don't think that was the original
agreement well no in the beginning it
was because they said they couldn't
afford it
my mother-in-law stayed at home at the
time and so my husband ended up he
couldn't afford it either as was prior
to our marriage
he ended up defaulting on one of the
loans and it went up in Kelton
collections and so once we got married
we were able to get a loan to get it out
of collections and we did seek their
help at that time and at that time they
were both working full-time they're
currently both working full-time
and they kind of strung us along and
months and months went by and we finally
just try to take care of it ourselves we
procured a loan for about eighty percent
of it and then my father actually loaned
us the remainder to get it out of
collections so we have since peed my dad
off but we're still sitting here you
know paying this entire loan ourselves
we're starting a young family and I
guess I just feel resentment for them
not coming up to the plate so yeah
how much how much money is involved here
um right now we owned and what's your
household income about forty eight I
stay home with our daughter I work a
little bit from home I'm currently not
making much but I do have opportunity to
advance it's just going to take a little
while and my husband is actually going
to be moving
step forward in his career as well so
our financial situation is due to
improve in the next year or two but it's
more just that was not the original
agreement and so so what is your husband
say about all this
well he's frustrated as well um
initially he just kind of swept it under
the rug that's sort of what they do in
their family and now he now that we have
a daughter our daughter just turned one
he is in a different frame of mind more
about protecting his family and doing
what it's financially best for us and so
he's very frustrated also but he's a
little bit more hesitant to say
something he's just not very good at
confrontation so I guess my question
meaning is just from an outside point of
view is it something that you think is
worth us pursuing or do you think we
should maybe just suck it up and pay it
I'd like to see your husband step up and
have a more healthy but firm
conversation with his parents without
you involved okay right because I think
they're going to hear the edge that's
that I hear in your voice it's been
about 12 years of frustration yeah and I
know I'm not saying you're wrong I just
hear the edge and you're the mother of
their grandkid right and I just I want I
don't want $10,000 to screw up this
whole thing well it's not worth it but
it probably is a good exercise for your
husband and his family to at least
address this mom and dad are you going
to do something here if you're not you
need to just tell me and if you're never
going to do anything that I'm just going
to let this go and I'm going to take
care of it but I mean we did have a deal
he needs to go say that out loud for his
manhood mhm and then if he comes back
and says look I they they don't think
there was a deal or they agree there's a
deed there was a deal but they're not
going to do anything about it we've got
a choice we can either be mad about it
or we can drop it
I'd suggest you drop it and pay it right
but I think it's a good exercise for
your husband as you said to stand up for
his kid here
in that sense and but but I don't I
don't think it to me I you know what I
think these people are the way you're
describing them it may be the way you're
describing them but what I heard was
they're lazy and they don't keep a lot
of commitments right they're saying
their life search their lives are
undisciplined and sloppy mm-hmm and then
they they are not very good with their
finances and thus they pass that on to
my husband so I think that's what's
going on I don't think these people I
think is people I have a bank load of
money and they're greedy and don't want
to help you I think they're just lazy
they're undisciplined they're
disorganized they're impulsive they're
immature they're selfish and you know
and I don't mean that in a but but
that's the downside of them they
probably are pretty loving and gentle
people too honestly but they're just
sloppy and right and I don't think
you're going to fix that with one
conversation and so I think he's
probably wasting his time on a practical
basis but I think it'll be good for him
and good for your marriage for him to
stand up and just get clarity on it I
think what you're going to decide both
of you is to forgive it
lay it down breathe in peace and pay the
bill that's probably what's going to
happen but don't don't don't don't don't
let $10,000 stay in your gut like it is
right now for the next ten years right
right that's not fair to you Samantha
that is very true you're not punishing
him you're punishing you right and every
time you say something about to about
the kids grandparents in front of the
kid there's a sneer in your voice you
don't want that
no absolutely absolutely so I would if
he or if he does if he does or if he
doesn't confront them one last time
ain't for clarity purposes and for
purposes of him standing with his
shoulders square that wouldn't be a bad
thing but if he doesn't do that or if he
does do that
ninety-eight percent chance you get no
money out of that confrontation ever and
so you do it gently tactfully but very
firmly and with a great clarity for the
sake of your husband's dignity because
now they're acting like they didn't have
a deal with him that they had
with him they messed over their own kid
and that somebody needs to say that out
loud from a justice perspective but then
once it's set out loud I just lay it
down and walk away
breathe in fix the deal vow to change
your family tree you and your husband
correct the things that that he
inherited in his character by attending
Financial Peace University or something
like that and you guys get your act
together and let's success be your best
revenge and move on it's what I would do
that that's how that I'm just you know
I'm just talking like an old grandpa
here hey thanks for the call